I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hi there!
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在制作专属于你们的终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当时在场的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好！嗨！
Are you excited to go to a super cringey fundraiser today? I am! I'm gonna get my best little hairdo going! Oh, I have fan questions about your hairdo, Angela! Save it! Okay, we have a lot to discuss. Today is Season 8, Episode 22. It was written by Owen Ellixson and directed by Dave Rogers. Here's your summary. The Dunder Mifflin
你对今天去一个超级尴尬的筹款活动感到兴奋吗？我很兴奋！我要去弄我最棒的小发型了！哦，我有关于你发型的粉丝提问，安吉拉！留着吧！好吧，我们有很多事情要讨论。今天是第八季第二十二集。它由欧文·埃利克森编剧，戴夫·罗杰斯执导。这是你的剧情摘要。邓德米夫林
group is concerned when newly unemployed Andy displays some questionable behavior both in the Dunder Mifflin parking lot and later at an animal welfare fundraiser hosted by the senator. Also at the fundraiser, Oscar becomes convinced that the senator is hitting on him. Dwight misunderstands the rules of a silent auction and Andy adopts 12 senior dogs. Andy, Andy, Andy, as someone who has worked an animal rescue, I can tell you that one needy animal, one animal that needs medications and ointments and salves is enough. You don't need 12. That's a hard job. I mean Aaron says this is my life now. All right fast-fact number one, Angela. You know how
集团感到担忧，因为刚失业的安迪在邓德米夫林停车场以及后来参议员主办的动物福利筹款活动上都表现出了一些可疑的行为。同样在筹款活动上，奥斯卡确信参议员在勾引他。德怀特误解了无声拍卖的规则，而安迪收养了12只老年犬。安迪，安迪，安迪，作为一个做过动物救援的人，我可以告诉你，一只需要照顾的动物，一只需要药物、软膏和药膏的动物就足够了。你不需要12只。这是一份艰巨的工作。我是说埃伦说这就是我现在的生。好吧，趣事一号，安吉拉。你知道吗
much I love when you do fast-fact number three and today you are doing fast back number one. I am okay for those of you guys that have the DVD box set. We are now on disc five and let me tell you There's some special features. First of all, fundraiser has an extended producers cut But there is also under the bonus section a 19-minute blooper reel, I watched the whole 19 minutes, it was a joy. I mean, if you need a laugh, watch a 19 minute blooper reel. I love our blooper reels.
我很喜欢你讲趣事三号，而今天你讲的是趣事一号。我好的，对于那些拥有DVD套装的人。我们现在在第五盘，让我告诉你们，有一些特别功能。首先，筹款活动有加长的制片人剪辑版，但在奖励部分还有一个19分钟的NG花絮集锦，我看了整整19分钟，真是太开心了。我是说，如果你需要笑一笑，就看19分钟的NG花絮集锦吧。我喜欢我们的NG花絮。
They're my favorite thing. Me too, they just take me back. Right away, we talk about this all the time that we went to work and tried not to laugh all day. What a blessing. Yes. Okay. It also has the Webisode series, The Girl Next Door, and apparently NBC was hosting Super Bowl 46. Oh yeah. And we did a bunch of promos, like a lot. And they're all on there to remind you guys, Super Bowl 46 was the New York Jets versus New England Patriots, the Jets 1, 21 to 17.
它们是我的最爱。我也是，它们把我带回了过去。我们经常谈论这一点，那就是我们去上班，整天都在努力不笑。真是太有福了。是的。好吧。它还有网络剧系列《隔壁女孩》，显然当时NBC正在举办第46届超级碗。哦，是的。我们做了很多宣传片，真的很多。它们都在那儿提醒大家，第46届超级碗是纽约喷气机队对阵新英格兰爱国者队，喷气机队以21比17获胜。
Kelly Clarkson sang the national anthem, and Madonna was the big half-time show. Well, I remember these promos. We did one promo with all of the NBC shows, and it was based on a musical number from how to succeed in business without really trying. And it kicked off with 30 rock, and then our cast sang part of it.
凯莉·克拉克森唱了国歌，麦当娜是盛大的中场秀。嗯，我记得这些宣传片。我们做过一个宣传片，里面有NBC所有的节目，它是根据音乐剧《平步青云》中的一首歌曲改编的。它以《我为人人》开场，然后我们剧组唱了其中的一部分。
It was, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, what's this song? Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, of men. Yes, yes. And da, da, da, da, da, da, da da da da da da da da da da da da da. You know, I'm horrible at this, right? Like, if I had to go on a game show and really lose badly, it would be like, guess the tune.
那是，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，这是什么歌？嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，男人的。是的，是的。还有哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒。你知道的，我在这方面糟透了，对吧？就像，如果我必须去参加一个游戏节目并且输得很惨，那就是猜曲调。
Because I'm just like, but I don't know. I can't in the company of men. Yes. Maybe. I'm going to say yes to everything. Okay. But it was huge. It was choreographed and we're lip syncing and it's so charming.
因为我就像，但我不知道。我不能在男人群中。是的。也许吧。我对一切都说好。好吧。但它规模很大。它是编排好的，我们在对口型，非常迷人。
And it was big. The full promo with all of the NBC people doing it was like, oh my gosh, six minutes, it was long. It was very long. It's so fun to watch. It is not on this DVD. Oh, never mind everyone. Google it.
而且规模很大。带有所有NBC员工参与的完整宣传片大概有，天哪，六分钟，很长。非常长。看这个太有趣了。它不在这个DVD上。哦，大家不用管了。去谷歌一下。
It is out there. Here are the Super Bowl promos on this DVD. First, there's a commercial where Kevin is really excited about the Super Bowl commercials. And then Robert, California pitches his idea for the perfect Super Bowl commercial. Mm-hmm. I'm scared. Yeah, you should be. It would feature a woman in her late 60s. And everywhere she goes, men fall to their knees, crippled with lust. She sees the camera while grocery shopping and drops her basket and looks right at the camera and says, this was all part of your plan, wasn't it Robert? And then Kevin says, wait, how can you do that?
它就在外面。以下是这张DVD上的超级碗宣传片。首先，有一个广告，凯文对超级碗广告非常兴奋。然后罗伯特·加利福尼亚提出了他关于完美超级碗广告的想法。嗯哼。我害怕。是的，你应该害怕。它将以一个60多岁的老妇人为主角。她走到哪里，男人都会跪倒在地，被情欲折磨得瘫痪。她在杂货店购物时看到了镜头，扔下篮子，直视镜头说，这一切都是你的计划的一部分，不是吗，罗伯特？然后凯文说，等等，你怎么能那样做？
How can you make the commercial different for every single person? And Robert goes, I don't know, I don't watch television. That's weird. I know. And this was made. Yes. It's on the DVD. It's on the DVD.
你怎么能为每个人制作不同的广告？罗伯特说，我不知道，我不看电视。这很奇怪。我知道。而这竟然被拍出来了。是的。它在DVD上。它在DVD上。
OK. The next promo was called Fans. And it's Andy and Aaron just saying, right to camera, you guys are going to the Super Bowl. That must be so exciting. And they're very cute and charming. Then there's one called museums. And it's John and Rain as themselves.
好吧。下一个宣传片叫《粉丝》。就是安迪和埃伦直接对着镜头说，你们要去超级碗了。那一定太激动人心了。他们非常可爱迷人。然后有一个叫《博物馆》的。是约翰和雷恩扮演他们自己。
But they're dressed in character and they're on set. And Rain is telling everyone what museums they should go to instead of going to the game. Okay. Okay. Like in hopes to get their tickets. Got it. It was very cute. There's one called Postgame where Ed is dressed as Andy and he's sitting in the manager's office and he's encouraging everyone to stick around after the Super Bowl to watch the post-game celebration. Okay. NBC really wanted people to stick around. Oh, that's why they always fight over who gets to air the Super Bowl.
但他们穿着戏服在片场。雷恩告诉大家应该去参观哪些博物馆，而不是去看比赛。好吧。好吧。就像为了拿到门票一样。明白了。非常可爱。有一个叫《赛后》的，埃德穿着安迪的衣服坐在经理办公室里，他鼓励大家在超级碗结束后留下来观看赛后庆祝活动。好吧。NBC真的很想让大家留下来。哦，这就是为什么他们总是争夺谁来转播超级碗。
I mean, first of all, obviously, the ad revenue. Right, right. But afterwards, they would use the Super Bowl to launch new shows or highlight shows that they really were excited about. Yeah, stick around after the Super Bowl. launch new shows or highlight shows that they really were excited about. Yeah. Stick around after the Super Bowl. Yeah. They say it all the time. And then my favorite one was called Dip.
我是说，首先，很明显，是为了广告收入。对，对。但随后，他们会利用超级碗来推出新节目或者重点宣传他们真正兴奋的节目。是啊，超级碗结束后留下来。推出新节目或者重点宣传他们真正兴奋的节目。是啊。超级碗结束后留下来。是啊。他们一直在说。然后我最喜欢的一个叫《蘸酱》。
And Kevin is going to share his perfect Super Bowl Dip recipe. You need to hear it. Brotherhood of Man. Yes. That's the name of the song. There you go. In honor of the Super Bowl, I have made 46 layer dip. Refried beans, ground beef, super salsa, bacon, ground cracker, bacon, seven layer dip, but all in one layer. Garden burger, turkey burger, beef burger, grilled cheese sandwiches. Kevin, I need that report by five. Oh! Now I have to start over, Andy.
凯文要分享他完美的超级碗蘸酱食谱。你得听听。人类兄弟会。是的。那是歌名。给你。为了纪念超级碗，我做了46层蘸酱。炸豆泥，碎牛肉，超级莎莎酱，培根，全麦饼干，培根，七层蘸酱，但都在同一层。花园汉堡，火鸡汉堡，牛肉汉堡，烤奶酪三明治。凯文，我五点前需要那份报告。哦！现在我得重新开始，安吉拉。
Gosh. Refried beans, ground beef, super sauce though. Everything was working for me, but the graham cracker was... That really threw you off. Yeah, that threw me off. There is an actual giant tub of this stuff and he's pointing to each layer. Oh my gosh.
天哪。炸豆泥，碎牛肉，超级莎莎酱。一切都对我很管用，但是全麦饼干……那真的把你难住了。是的，那把我难住了。这里有一个实际装着这东西的巨大桶，他指着每一层。哦，天哪。
I'm going to put a picture of it in stories. Okay, please. It looks disgusting. And those are the bonus features on the last disc of season 8. That was a very good report, Angela. I enjoyed it very much. Okay, well, thank you. Let's move on to fast fact number two.
我要在快拍里发一张照片。好的，拜托。看起来太恶心了。这些就是第八季最后一张光盘上的花絮。这是一份非常好的报告，安吉拉。我非常喜欢。好吧，谢谢。让我们继续第二条趣事。
One of the storylines in this week's episode was inspired by a true story. Yes. So you know, at the charity event, they have a silent auction, but Dwight thinks this is a guess the price game and that you win the prize if you guess the correct price. Yeah.
本周剧集中的一条故事线灵感来源于真实故事。是的。所以你知道，在慈善活动中，他们有一个无声拍卖，但德怀特认为这是一个猜价格的游戏，如果你猜对价格就能赢得奖品。是的。
Well this happened to our writer, Hallstead Sullivan's sister in real life. I cannot believe that. It's so crazy to tell the story. So he was working at the office at the time and his sister called him on the phone and was like, Halstead, I won this expensive Italian sofa at this event last night.
这发生在我们的编剧霍尔斯特德·沙利文的姐姐身上。我真不敢相信。讲这个故事太疯狂了。所以他当时在办公室工作，他姐姐给他打电话说，霍尔斯特德，我昨晚在这个活动上赢得了这张昂贵的意大利沙发。
It's worth $17,000 and I guessed the price exactly and I won. Oh my gosh. And he was like, that's amazing. Congratulations. But then cut to a few days later, she called him to say that the charity sent her a really weird letter asking her to pay for the sofa. And he said, fax me the letter. When Hall said it was retelling the story, he said, old Teckelert, he said, faxed me the letter. When Hall said it was retelling the story, he said, old tech alert, yes, she faxed me the letter from the charity. And he
它价值17,000美元，我完全猜中了价格，我赢了。哦，天哪。他说，太棒了。恭喜。但几天后，她打电话告诉他，慈善机构给她寄了一封非常奇怪的信，要求她支付沙芬的钱。他说，把信传真给我。当霍尔斯特德重述这个故事时，他说，老科技警报，是的，她把慈善机构的信传真给我了。他
looked it over and he had to explain to her that it was not a guess the price. It was a silent auction and that her bid for the sofa was $17,000 and they wanted to collect. Oh my gosh. He said she panicked. Well, yeah. He also said in her defense, there was an Italian man with an accent who had explained the rules to her and perhaps something got lost in translation, but she called the charity, she explained the mistake,
仔细查看了信，不得不向她解释这不是猜价格。这是一场无声拍卖，她对沙发的出价是17,000美元，他们想要收钱。哦，天哪。他说她惊慌失措。嗯，是的。他还说，为她辩护一下，当时有一个带口音的意大利男人向她解释了规则，可能有些东西在翻译中失真了，但她打电话给慈善机构，解释了这个错误，
and they did not make her pay $17,000. Holstead said he recognized the sofa she bid on. It was a Dessedi sofa, Dessed, D-E-S-E-D-E. It is an Italian sofa, which is basically the Barken bag of sofas. $17,000 is actually a bargain. I can't even wrap my head around that number. That's a car. Yeah, that's like you're sitting on a car. Well, Halstead said he only recognized it because,
他们没有让她付17,000美元。霍尔斯特德说他认出了她竞标的沙发。那是德塞迪沙发，德塞迪，D-E-S-E-D-E。它是一款意大利沙发，基本上相当于沙发中的铂金包。17,000美元其实是个便宜货。我甚至无法想象这个数字。那是一辆车。是的，就像你坐在车上一样。好吧，霍尔斯特德说他认出它只是因为，
before they wrote on the office, he and Warren had written for a show produced by Will Smith and Jada Pinkett Smith, and they had one of these sofas. Oh! It was written up in like, and they had one of these sofas. Oh! It was written up in like, you know, one of those profiles they do of celebrity homes. And I looked at the website, most of these sofas go for around $40,000. Wow. And I'm very sorry to say it or to say sofa company,
在他们为《办公室》写剧本之前，他和沃伦曾为威尔·史密斯和贾达·萍克特·史密斯制作的一部剧写过剧本，他们就有一个这样的沙发。哦！它被报道过，你知道的，在名人住宅的那些专题报道中。我看了网站，这些沙发大多售价在40,000美元左右。哇。我很抱歉这么说，或者说沙发公司，
but they are ugly. I'm just gonna say it. They are, were you sending me a picture of one? Yes. I mean, do you wanna see it? Yeah, are they comfortable? They can't be $40,000 comfortable. They don't, nothing is $40,000 comfortable.
但它们太丑了。我只想这么说。它们确实是，你刚才在给我发照片吗？是的。我是说，你想看看吗？是的，它们舒服吗？它们不可能舒服得值40,000美元。它们不，没有什么舒服得值40,000美元。
Like if you take the most comfortable $1,500 couch, it is not, this special sofa is not 40 times more comfortable than it. You know what, we have a couch for my Kea that Josh put together himself. And when he said I'm gonna put it together, I thought maybe it comes in four pieces you screw on the legs.
就像如果你买最舒服的1,500美元的沙发，它也不是，这款特殊的沙发没有它40倍那么舒服。你知道吗，我们有一个宜家的沙发，是乔希自己组装的。当他说我要组装它时，我以为它可能分成四块，你把腿拧上去。
You know what I mean? Uh-huh. No, Jenna. There's a box. It's just the stuffing. Then you got to like stuff it and you got to like, you literally build a couch. And I thought, wow, this, we're getting such a deal on this sectional. It's because you build the whole damn thing. Yes, there's no, well, they don't charge you for any labor because you are the labor. It took a whole day. But is it comfortable? Yes. Right. Now, I just, here's the website. Oh, no. Right. This is ridiculous. One of their things is that they make like a snake sofa. It doesn't look like a snake, but you can, I guess, make it into an S shape. I'll try you. It's a giant sea.
你知道我的意思吗？嗯哼。不，珍妮弗。有一个箱子。里面只有填充物。然后你得像塞满它，你得像，你字面意义上是自己造了一个沙发。我想，哇，我们在这个组合沙发上赚大了。那是因为你把整个该死的东西都自己造了。是的，没有，嗯，他们不收取任何人工费，因为你就是劳动力。花了一整天时间。但它舒服吗？是的。好吧。现在，我只是，这是网站。哦，不。对。这太荒谬了。他们的一大特色是他们制作类似蛇形沙发的沙发。它看起来不像蛇，但我想你可以把它变成S形。我试给你看。这是一个巨大的C形。
It's very... It's like a curved spine for those of you listening. Yes, it's tiny. It looks very spiny. It looks like a spine. And yeah, so it looks like if you took an X-ray of your back, but... And turned it into...
它非常……对于听众朋友们来说，它看起来像一条弯曲的脊椎。是的，它很小。看起来很有脊椎感。它看起来像脊椎。是的，所以它看起来就像你背部的X光片，但是……把它变成了……
To leather sofa. To leather sofa. But then the way the cushions look It looks like if you chopped a recliner and three pieces Mm-hmm, and then you just put them all in a row tons of mini Like spine recliners Today's podcast is sponsored by the set a sofa. It is definitely not Sorry sorry to set a or to said you don't know what's saying it wrong. We don't know is definitely not. Sorry, sorry, Dicetti, or Dicetti.
变成皮质沙发。变成皮质沙发。但随后靠垫的外观看起来就像你把一把躺椅切成三块，嗯哼，然后把它们排成一排，里面有大量的迷你版类似脊椎的躺椅。今天的播客由德塞迪沙发赞助。它绝对不是抱歉，抱歉，塞迪或者塞迪你不知道是在读错。我们不知道。抱歉，抱歉，迪塞迪或者迪塞迪。
You don't know us staying at wrong. We don't know. We don't know. What we know is that we won't be purchasing one of your sofas for so many reasons. Sorry. I love that this white storyline was inspired by a true life event in Halstead's life. It was really funny, too.
你不知道我们读错了。我们不知道。我们不知道。我们知道的是，由于种种原因，我们不会购买你们的沙发。抱歉。我很喜欢德怀特的这条故事线灵感来自于霍尔斯特德生活中的真实事件。而且真的很有趣。
Yeah, he was so happy he was getting everything right. I really liked it. Should we move on to FastFact number three? Yes, because it's so special. We love this letter that we got from Alicia H. In my long Wisconsin, she wrote to us because this is the fundraiser episode. Yeah.
是的，他太高兴了，因为他把一切都弄对了。我真的很喜欢。我们应该进入第三条趣事吗？是的，因为这太特别了。我们很喜欢我们收到来自威斯康星州的艾丽西亚·H的这封信。她在信中写道，因为这是筹款集。是的。
And she is having a fundraiser for her local library. Alicia said the building that the library is housed in was put up for sale last summer, and the community is working really hard to save the library. She said most of the families that the library serves are below the poverty line, and the library has so many wonderful programs. Her own four kids begged her to go all the time. It's like their second home. And she said that she would really like us to help support the library. She will even buy us tacos.
她正在为当地图书馆筹款。艾丽西亚说，图书馆所在的建筑去年夏天被挂牌出售，社区正在努力拯救图书馆。她说，图书馆服务的大多数家庭都在贫困线以下，图书馆有这么多精彩的项目。她自己的四个孩子求她一直去。这就像他们的第二个家。她说她真的很希望我们能支持图书馆。她甚至会给我们买塔可。
Well, Alicia, we loved your letter. We loved learning about your local library, which is 100% run by volunteers. Yes. If you go to their website, you can learn so much about what this library does for its community. It's a small community, and for those of you that live in small towns, you know that the library can be such a wonderful place to go with your kids. And you have access to things you might not be able to have at home or afford. Very well said, Angela.
好吧，艾丽西亚，我们很喜欢你的信。我们很高兴了解到你们当地的图书馆，这里100%由志愿者运营。是的。如果你去他们的网站，你可以了解到很多关于这个图书馆为社区所做的事情。这是一个小社区，对于住在小镇的人来说，你知道图书馆是一个可以和孩子们一起去的 maravilhoso（精彩的）地方。你可以接触到你在家里可能无法拥有或负担得起的东西。说得太好了，安吉拉。
Well, Alicia, each year, Office Ladies does some annual giving and we are adding your library to our list to this year. We're gonna make a donation. Yep. We're also gonna send you a signed copy of the Office BFFs and the Actors' Life for the library. Love it.
好吧，艾丽西亚，每年《办公室女郎》都会进行一些年度捐赠，今年我们将把你们的图书馆加入我们的名单。我们要进行捐赠。是的。我们还将为你寄一本签名版的《办公室好闺蜜》和《演员的生活》给图书馆。太棒了。
And speaking of our annual giving, this year we are also giving to Black Girls Code, AMSCI and Liday Hady. Liday Hady is the organization that Rain Wilson and his wife, Holiday Rainhorn, started. And you recently went to a fundraiser with Steve Carell for Liday Hady. That was hosted by Rain, right? We did. It was really fun.
说到我们的年度捐赠，今年我们还将捐赠给“黑人女孩写代码”组织、AMSCI和Liday Hady。Liday Hady是雷恩·威尔逊和他的妻子霍利·雷恩霍恩创立的组织。你最近和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起去参加了一个为Liday Hady筹款的活动。那是雷恩主持的，对吧？是的。真的很棒。
Rain put together sort of this quote-unquote dinner party. Amazing. Amazing, right? And Steve and I went along with a lot of people that made donations to Liday and the people that work at Liday. And we got to hear about everything they're doing in Haiti. It's really an amazing organization. Rain has such a big heart for service.
雷恩组织了这种所谓的晚宴。太棒了，对吧？史蒂夫和我一起去了，还有许多向Liday捐款的人以及在Liday工作的人。我们听取了他们在海地所做的一切。这真的是一个了不起的组织。雷恩有一颗多么热心服务的心啊。
He and his wife Holly do so much. And I'm going to put a link to their website in our stories. But Liday is a nonprofit, and what they're trying to do is empower adolescent Haitian girls through programs in the arts, education, and health. I think we should post links to all the organizations we spoke about today so that people can see the amazing things that these groups are doing.
他和他的妻子霍利做了很多事。我将在我们的快拍中附上他们网站的链接。但Liday是一个非营利组织，他们试图做的是通过艺术、教育和健康方面的项目，赋予海地女青少年权力。我认为我们应该发布我们今天讨论过的所有组织的链接，以便人们能够看到这些团体正在做的了不起的事情。
I love that. Well, that's all I got, lady. Should we take a break? I think we should, because when we come back, I have a little something for my digital clutter. I love digital clutter. Someday I'm going to clean up my inbox. I am.
我喜欢这样。好了，这就是我的全部内容，女士。我们应该休息一下吗？我想我们应该，因为当我们回来时，我要为我的数字杂乱做点小准备。我喜欢数字杂乱。总有一天我要清理我的收件箱。我会的。
Please don't. We'll be right back. We are back and I have an email for you all that came on Saturday, March 31, 2012 at 313 PM. Who would it come from? Dave Rogers to the entire cast of the office. The subject was, wow, exclamation point. Here's what it said. I just finished my editor's assembly of fundraiser and I am thrilled with how it turned out. So many great laugh out loud moments from everybody. We have made some truly great episodes this
请不要。我们马上回来。我们回来了，我有一封电子邮件要发给大家，它是2012年3月31日星期六下午3点13分收到的。它是谁发给我的？戴夫·罗杰斯发给《办公室》全体演员的。主题是：哇，惊叹号。内容是这样的：我刚刚完成了《筹款活动》的剪辑汇编，我对它的效果感到非常兴奋。每个人都有那么多让人捧腹大笑的时刻。我们在这
season and have seriously kicked ass with our Florida arc. What an incredible run with Tallahassee after hours tests the store last day in Florida and get the girl soon to be joined by the hysterical welcome party, Angry Andy and Turfour. Gotta go, free family portrait studio isn't gonna edit itself. David, I have to tell you in all my years of working on things since the office. This doesn't happen. You don't get letters from your editor or your director even. Like I don't get letters just saying, guess what? It's great. You're great. This is so fun. You're doing a good thing. Way to go, team. Yeah. We got this kind of stuff on this show. It was so sweet.
一季制作了一些真正伟大的剧集，并且我们的佛罗里达故事线大获成功。塔拉哈西之夜测试了商店在佛罗里达的最后一天，还有接女孩，不久之后还将加入搞笑的欢迎派对、愤怒的安迪和四号。得走了，免费家庭肖像工作室可不会自己剪辑。大卫，我必须告诉你，在我离开《办公室》之后工作的这些年里。这是不会发生的。你甚至不会收到你的剪辑师或导演的信。就像我不会收到信说，猜怎么着？这太棒了。你太棒了。这太有趣了。你做得很好。干得好，团队。是的。我们在这个节目里得到了这种东西。太温馨了。
And everyone responded back. Mindy so sweet. And everyone responded back. Mindy was the first one that responded back. She wrote, I love you Dave. And everybody was like, thanks, everything. Yay, can't wait to see. You know, that's so sweet. Yeah. And this is why I don't delete any of my emails.
每个人都回复了。明迪太贴心了。每个人都回复了。明迪是第一个回复的。她写道：我爱你，戴夫。每个人都说：谢谢，一切都好。耶，迫不及待想看。你知道，这太贴心了。是的。这就是为什么我从不删除任何电子邮件。
Are you ready for this cold open? I think so. Well, Ryan is pacing back and forth. He is going, no, no, no, no, no, no. By the way, he's not saying this in his office. His closet office, he's not pacing in the kitchen. He's come into the bullpen to pace back and forth until someone notices.
你们准备好迎接这个开场白了吗？我想是的。好吧，瑞恩在来回踱步。他一直在说，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。顺便说一句，他不是在自己的办公室里这么说。他的壁橱办公室，他不是在厨房里踱步。他来到大办公区来回踱步，直到有人注意到。
Yes. Pam finally gives in and asks him what is bothering you. Ryan, something seems to be bothering you. And it turns out that he is very, very upset that Smokey Robinson has died and he didn't get a chance to see him in concert before he died. People are sad, you know, Jim's like, oh I liked him and Ryan's like, you liked him? Because apparently Smokey's biggest fan is Ryan. That's right. No one else can even compare to like how much he loved Smokey's biggest fan is Ryan. That's right, no one else can even compare
是的。潘终于妥协了，问他到底在烦什么。瑞恩，似乎有什么事在困扰你。原来他非常非常难过，因为斯莫基·罗宾逊去世了，而他在他死前没能有机会去看他的演唱会。人们很难过，你知道，吉姆说，哦，我喜欢他，瑞恩说，你喜欢他？因为显然斯莫基最大的粉丝就是瑞恩。没错。没有人能比得上他有多喜欢斯莫基最大的粉丝就是瑞恩。没错，没有人能比得上
to how much he loves Smokey. Well, Pam is a little suspicious, right? She always has Ryan's number. And she's kind of like, we've never heard you talk about this before, ever. Like, this is a first and suddenly Oscar, from over an accounting says, guys, it's a hoax. Yeah, he's not dead, he's alive,
他有多喜欢斯莫基。好吧，潘有点怀疑，对吧？她总是很了解瑞恩。她有点像，我们以前从没听你谈过这个，从来没有。就像，这是第一次，突然间，会计室的奥斯卡说，伙计们，这是个恶作剧。是的，他没死，他还活着，
and he's got a concert coming up. Ryan, you should go. Everyone says. Well, it's really Pam. It's really Pam. Pam was like, you have to go. Jim's like, tickets are $250. Pam's like, $250 is nothing to the world's biggest, smoky Robinson fan. And Ryan's like, well, who's opening? Jim says, Paul Anke. And Ryan's like, well, who's opening? Jim says Paul Anka.
他马上要开演唱会了。瑞恩，你应该去。每个人都说。好吧，其实是潘。其实是潘。潘就像，你必须去。吉姆说，票价250美元。潘说，250美元对世界上最伟大的斯莫基·罗宾逊粉丝来说算什么。瑞恩说，那谁是暖场嘉宾？吉姆说，保罗·安卡。瑞恩说，那谁是暖场嘉宾？吉姆说保罗·安卡。
And Ryan's like, oh, what? No, I can't, I'm sorry, I can't do it, I can't do it. I mean, this is my favorite version of Pam. I think when she takes on Ryan. Yes, now that we have been rewatching now for years, my favorite version of Pam is when she just looks at him and just calls him out. I loved how she was like name another song, name one other song of his. And he's like, he can't. Well, I looked up Smokey Robinson. He has been in the rock and roll Hall of Fame twice.
瑞恩说，哦，什么？不，我不行，对不起，我做不到，我做不到。我是说，这是我最喜欢的潘的版本。我认为当她对付瑞恩时。是的，既然我们已经重温了好几年，我最喜欢的潘的版本就是她看着他并当面拆穿他。我喜欢她那种语气，说出他的另一首歌，说出一首他的别的歌。他说，他不能。好吧，我查了一下斯莫基·罗宾逊。他两次进入摇滚名人堂。
He's been inducted. And he's written more than 4,000 songs. So the fact that Ryan can't name a second song is pretty bad. Smokey Robinson is 83 years old and he is still performing live and you can find his tour dates at smokeyrobbinson.com and he's got shows coming up in Atlantic City, Providence, Rhode Island, and Nashville, Tennessee. Go Smokey Robinson. Ryan can still go. Yes, Ryan, go. You're his biggest fan. The episode starts with Robert California arriving in a dark brown suit and tie. He looks like really put together.
他入选了。他写了4,000多首歌。所以瑞恩连第二首歌都说不出来，这真的很糟糕。斯莫基·罗宾逊今年83岁，他仍在进行现场演出，你可以在 smokeyrobinson.com 上找到他的巡演日期，他即将在大西洋城、罗德岛普罗维登斯和田纳西州纳什维尔举办演出。加油，斯莫基·罗宾逊。瑞恩还是可以去的。是的，瑞恩，去吧。你是他最大的粉丝。剧集开始时，罗伯特·加利福尼亚穿着深棕色西装和领带到达。他看起来真的很整洁。
The suit looks great, but he says he really hates wearing ties. He feels like he's in one of those erotic, what's it called? Asphyxiation. Thank you. Yes. Yeah. And he mentions a few off of Interstate 84. Mm-hmm. I looked them up.
西装看起来很棒，但他却说他真的很讨厌打领带。他觉得自己就像在那些色情片里，叫什么来着？窒息式性爱。谢谢。是的。是的，他提到了84号州际公路旁的一些地方。嗯哼。我查了。
They're not real. I looked them up too. I couldn't find them. I was glad I didn't. I don't know how I ended up here, but I did find out that there's quite a few swingers gloves in Scranton. Yeah, I guess. How's that work?
它们不是真的。我也查了。我找不到。我很庆幸我没有。我不知道我是怎么落到这里的，但我确实发现斯克兰顿有很多换妻俱乐部。是的，我猜。那是怎么运作的？
I don't know. fingers clubs in Scranton? Yeah, I guess. How's that work? I don't know. It says most clubs offered by Pennsylvania's Swingers are for members only. However, couples and singles can get this membership as well. How does a single join a swingers club? I don't know. The closest club I found to Scranton is in Bloomsburg and Erotic Ex-fixi, no, no, it's a Swingers Club. Oh, I went to look for these clubs and I ended up on a Scranton Swingers website.
我不知道。斯克兰顿有换妻俱乐部？是的，我猜。那是怎么运作的？我不知道。上面说宾夕法尼亚州换妻俱乐部的大多数俱乐部都只对会员开放。不过，情侣和单身人士也可以获得这种会员资格。单身人士怎么加入换妻俱乐部？我不知道。我找到的离斯克兰顿最近的俱乐部在布卢姆斯堡，还有色情窒息，不，不，这是一个换妻俱乐部。哦，我去寻找这些俱乐部，结果误打误撞进了一个斯克兰顿换妻网站。
Oh, and now if you want to swing, you have to go where? Bloomsburg. Bloomsburg. So there you go. Well, that was an interesting Google journey for you. Oh, yes, it was. Also, BY for you. Oh, yes, it was also BYUB just It's so it's a room basically. I don't know. I didn't look any further. It's a basement. Okay. Okay Angela is gonna have a talking head where she says Here's what's going on the senator is hosting a fundraiser for local dog shelters tonight and Robert, California, but two tables.
哦，现在如果你想换妻，你得去哪儿？布卢姆斯堡。布卢姆斯堡。所以就这样吧。好吧，这对你来说真是一次有趣的谷歌搜索之旅。哦，是的，确实是。还有BYUB，只是……它基本上是一个房间。我不知道。我没有再深究。它是一个地下室。好吧。好吧，安吉拉有一个单人访谈，她说事情是这样的，参议员今晚要为当地的动物收容所举办一个筹款活动，罗伯特·加利福尼亚订了两张桌子。
Yeah. And invited the whole office staff. And you know what? They were lucky to get seats because it's going to be a who's who of the Northern 22nd District. Yeah. And Angela's going to do her hair. Oh, she's going to get her hair did. Dwight burst into the bullpen. He doesn't want to alarm everyone, but there's a good chance
是的。并邀请了整个办公室的员工。你知道吗？他们能有座位就很幸运了，因为这将是北部第22区各界名流的聚会。是的。而且安吉拉要去做发型。哦，她要去做发型了。德怀特冲进办公区。他不想惊动大家，但很有可能会
that someone's gonna get hurt today. Yeah, because there's a disgruntled former employee sitting in their car in the parking lot. Guess who it is? It's Andy. It's Andy. Guys, Andy cannot let go of Dundra Mifflin. He's become the lurker. Mm-hmm. You know, during this scene, I noticed the little candy dispenser on my desk. Yeah. It's the one that used to be at reception, and we decided that for whatever reason,
有人今天会受伤。是的，因为停车场里有一名前雇员正坐在车里生闷气。猜猜是谁？是安迪。是安迪。伙计们，安迪就是放不下邓德米夫林。他成了潜伏者。嗯哼。你知道，在这场戏中我注意到了我桌子上的小糖果机。是的。就是以前在前台那个，我们决定无论出于什么原因，
Pam would move it to her desk. This is why Aaron has to put out candy in a glass bowl. Yeah. So this little candy dispenser, I saw it was in it. What? Red hots. Oh. And I know why there were red hots in it, what? Red hots. Oh. And I know why there were red hots in it, because I would eat all the other candies, but
潘会把它搬到她的桌子上。这就是为什么埃伦必须在一个玻璃碗里摆放糖果。是的。所以这个小糖果机，我看到里面有。什么？红辣糖。哦。我知道为什么里面有红辣糖，什么？红辣糖。哦。我知道为什么里面有红辣糖，因为我会吃掉所有其他的糖果，但是
you wouldn't eat the red hots. I wouldn't eat the red hots. So I said, Phil, I need you to put something in this container that I don't eat all day, because I was getting tummy aches. It was too much sugar. So he said, what won't you eat? And I said, I won't eat michen eggs, and I won't eat red hots. So he put red what won't you eat? And I said, I won't eat micanikes and I won't eat redhots.
你不会吃红辣糖。我不会吃红辣糖。所以我说，菲尔，我需要你在容器里放一些我不会一整天都吃的东西，因为我开始胃疼了。糖分太多了。所以他说，你不会吃什么？我说，我不会吃薄荷巧克力，我也不会吃红辣糖。所以他放了红，你不会吃什么？我说，我不会吃薄荷巧克力，我也不会吃红辣糖。
So he put redhots in there. So if you ever see micanikes or redhots and my candy dispenser, it was per my request because I was needing to stop my candy eating. Well, I noticed that your fingernail polish is the exact same color as your coffee mug. It's kind of a pinky purple in this episode. I don't know why I was allowed to do that, but it matches my dress for the fundraiser very well.
所以他在里面放了红辣糖。所以如果你在我的糖果机里看到薄荷巧克力或红辣糖，那是应我的要求放的，因为我需要戒掉吃糖的习惯。好吧，我注意到你的指甲油颜色和你的咖啡杯一模一样。在这集里有点粉紫色。我不知道为什么我被允许这样做，但它和我在筹款活动上穿的裙子非常搭。
Aaron and Angela, Pam, Kevin and Jim are all now gonna go to the parking lot. They're gonna check in on Andy, like what's he doing? He's sitting in his car, what's happening? Aaron is filming him, she said, hey, can we just film you saying that you're fine and everything's normal,
埃伦和安吉拉、潘、凯文和吉姆现在都要去停车场。他们要去看看安迪，看看他在干什么？他坐在车里，发生什么事了？埃伦在拍他，她说，嘿，我们能拍一段你说你很好而且一切正常的视频吗？
because there were, he might hurt Robert. He says, guys, I am fine. I'm just picking up Aaron for the fundraiser tonight. Kevin is the one that's like, that's gonna be weird. Like Kevin's the one that clocks in on this? I was like, what? Kevin is the voice of reason through this entire episode. It's a wonderful turn. Well, Brian could not get through the scene. He
因为有，他可能会伤害罗伯特。他说，伙计们，我很好。我只是来接埃伦去今晚的筹款活动。凯文说这会很奇怪。就像凯文是那个察觉到这一点的人吗？当时我想，什么？凯文是整集中唯一讲道理的人。这是一个美妙的转变。好吧，布赖恩在这场戏里演不下去了。他
kept getting tickled. It's in the bloopers that I watched all 19 minutes of and I want you to hear it. I'm picking up Aaron. We're going to the fundraiser. Oh great. That sounds good. Wait, what? You're going to the fundraiser tonight? That's gonna be weird. Well, that'd be weird. Yeah, Kevin, come on, it's gonna be fine. It's not weird at all. Am I the only, my, uh-huh. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
一直笑场。这就在我看过的那整整19分钟的NG花絮里，我想让你们听听。我来接埃伦。我们要去筹款活动。哦，太棒了。听起来不错。等等，什么？你们今晚要去筹款活动？那会很奇怪。好吧，那很奇怪。是的，凯文，得了吧，这会很好的。一点也不奇怪。难道只有我一个人，我的，嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。
Ready? Mm-hmm. Yeah, that's not weird at all. Oh, boy. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Oh, my gosh. It's John.
准备好了吗？嗯哼。是的，一点也不奇怪。哦，天哪。嗯哼。嗯哼。哦，天哪。是约翰。
It's John and Brian. Yeah, John is messing with him. Brian was trying so hard if you watch it to say the line. So he's trying to kind of laugh through it like, um, but he couldn't do it. Now we go upstairs to Nellie's office. Daryl is going to enter and ask her to sign off on a shipment that's gonna go out soon. Nelly's gonna ask Darryl how everything's going in the warehouse and he says, well, you know what, you can go downstairs and check it out for yourself. And she's like, oh, it's downstairs. She's so aware it is. Did you notice Nelly's desk chair by any chance?
是约翰和布赖恩。是的，约翰在捉弄他。如果你看的话，布赖恩为了说出台词一直在努力憋笑。所以他试图笑着把台词说过去，比如，呃，但他做不到。现在我们上楼去内莉的办公室。达里尔走进来，请她在不久后将要发出的一批货上签字。内莉问达里尔仓库里的情况怎么样，他说，嗯，你知道吗，你可以自己下楼去看看。她说，哦，在楼下啊。她太清楚在哪儿了。你注意到内莉的办公椅了吗？
No. It's like this topy cream color. It's like a faux leather. It's like this topy cream color. It's like a faux leather. It's very nice. It is not the chair that Steve sat in or Ed sat in or Creed anyone. It's this new chair. I became sort of obsessed with it.
没有。就像这种灰褐色奶油色。就像人造皮革。就像这种灰褐色奶油色。就像人造皮革。非常漂亮。它不是史蒂夫坐的椅子，也不是埃德或克里德任何人坐的椅子。是这把新椅子。我有点对它着迷了。
I wanted to know how did this happen? Where did this chair come from? When did it come from? And I fully mom detective it. I don't have a great answer but I spent a good deal of time on it. That is mom detectives. That is we rarely solve our crimes. Well, this is our mysteries, I should say. Isn't our slogan solving crimes no one cares about? Or not solving crimes that no one cares about. So not necessarily a crime, but a mystery. Where did this chair come from?
我想知道这是怎么回事？这椅子从哪来的？什么时候来的？我完全像妈妈侦探一样去调查了。我没有一个很好的答案，但我花了很多时间在这上面。这就是妈妈侦探。这就是我们很少能破案。好吧，这是我们的悬案，我应该这么说。我们的口号难道不是侦破无人关心的案件吗？或者说是不侦破无人关心的案件。所以不一定是犯罪，而是一个谜。这把椅子是从哪儿来的？
So I went back and I looked to see when did it appear. And get the girl, it's the old chair. We don't see her chair in Welcome Party, but then the new chair is there starting with angry Andy. So I think we can safely say that this new chair came during welcome party when Dwight and Jim went to her house to unpack her things that had been delivered. I think that there is something that happened off camera where they brought this new office chair into the office. So you think she had the fancy office chair in her apartment? Yes. I think it was delivered with her other furniture and then she moved it in because starting with Angry Andy, she's really
所以我回去看了看它是什时候出现的。在《接女孩》里，那是旧椅子。我们在《欢迎派对》里没看到她的椅子，但从《愤怒的安迪》开始新椅子就在那儿了。所以我想我们可以有把握地说，这把新椅子是在《欢迎派对》期间德怀特和吉姆去她家搬运送到的物品时拿来的。我认为发生了一些镜头外的事，他们把这把新办公椅搬进了办公室。所以你认为她公寓里有豪华办公椅？是的。我认为它是和她其他家具一起送到的，然后她把它搬了进来，因为从《愤怒的安迪》开始，她真的
taken over his office and I think she brought in her new chair. Okay. Is it a dissed a chair? Yeah. It could be. It doesn't look ugly enough in my opinion. Oh my gosh, you are fully. You're really laying it out there. Why am I so mean to this luxury Italian couch? Something about it. It just, it buffed you. It bothers me. I don't know.
接管了他的办公室，我想她把她的新椅子拿来了。好吧。这是一把迪塞迪椅子吗？是的。有可能是。在我看来，它看起来还不够丑。哦，天哪，你太较真了。你真的是直言不讳。为什么我对这个豪华意大利沙发这么苛刻？某种原因。它就是惹恼了你。它困扰着我。我不知道。
It should be the most beautiful couch I've ever seen in my opinion. It should be able to drive. Yes, exactly. What is the couch do? And the wheels come out. It should be able to drive. Yes, exactly. What is the catabuy? And the wheels come out and you take it down the road. Nelly is now gonna have a talking head where she says tonight could be the night she and Darryl become good friends.
在我看来，它应该是我见过最漂亮的沙发。它应该会开车。是的，exactly（没错）。沙发能做什么？轮子伸出来。它应该会开车。是的，exactly（没错）。沙发能买什么？轮子伸出来，你就能把它开上路。内莉现在要有一个单人访谈，她说今晚可能是她和达里尔成为好朋友的夜晚。
The only thing in their way is the contempt he feels for her. So I was wondering why is it important for Nelly to become friends with Darryl? And I realized that this is setting up a storyline that's gonna pay off in a few episodes where you realize that Nelly really doesn't have any friends since she moved to Scranton. Yeah.
唯一阻碍他们的就是他对她的蔑视。所以我想知道为什么对内莉来说和达里尔成为朋友很重要？我意识到这是在为接下来的几集中的一个情节做铺垫，到时你会发现内莉自从搬到斯克兰顿后真的没有任何朋友。是的。
And this is kind of important to her. I liked this. I liked that we're planning the seed with this storyline. Yeah. She wants a friend in the office. Yes. The fundraiser is now underway. We're going to see Angela in her outfit. She's very much wanting to play the part of the Senator's wife here. Robert California walks up and is interrupted by Andy. And lady, I just wanted you to know this little introduction when Robert walks up. And Angela greets him and is like,
这对她来说挺重要的。我喜欢这样。我喜欢我们在剧情中埋下伏笔。是的。她想在办公室里有个朋友。是的。筹款活动正在进行中。我们要看安吉拉的打扮。她非常想在这里扮演参议员妻子的角色。罗伯特·加利福尼亚走过来，被安迪打断了。女士们，当罗伯特走过来时，我只是想让你们知道这个小小的开场白。
the senator and I just wanted to say, you know, she's doing like that. That was all improvised. Oh, all it said in the script is that everyone says, hi, good to see you. Oh, well, well done, I liked it. I was so delighted by this episode. I just love it when Angela Martin thinks she's fancy and is trying to be fancy.
安吉拉迎接他说，参议员和我只想说，你知道，她就是那样做的。那全都是即兴发挥的。哦，剧本里唯一写的是每个人都说，嗨，很高兴见到你。哦，好吧，干得好，我很喜欢。我对这一集感到非常高兴。我就是喜欢安吉拉·马丁自以为很fancy（高档）并试图表现得很fancy的时候。
And every single moment I just wanted to find some little nugget of something to do to show how high the stakes were for her to be the senator's wife at this event. Well, speaking of fancy, fan question from Katie Joby in Indiana. Hi Katie Jo. Angela, how did you feel about your judged hairdo at the fundraiser? Did you have an extensive hair meeting like Jenna would have? Did you love getting to smile so much in this episode?
在每一个时刻，我都想找到一些表演的小细节，来展现她作为活动中参议员的妻子，赌注有多高。好吧，说到高档，来自印第安纳州的凯蒂·乔比的粉丝提问。嗨，凯蒂·乔。安吉拉，你对自己在筹款活动上的评判性发型有什么感觉？你们像珍妮弗那样开过详尽的发型会议吗？你喜欢在这集里笑得那么多吗？
Ha, ha, ha. You know, it was nice to smile. There is one scene. I will tell you Katie, where I didn't get to smile. It got deleted, but we did shoot it where I completely lose it because Andy is ruining my event. Oh. Yes, I go to the center and I'm like, he's ruining it and I'm just like upset. But for the most part, I got to smile this whole week,
哈哈，你知道，笑的感觉真好。有一个场景。我告诉你，凯蒂，我没能笑出来。它被删掉了，但我们确实拍了，我彻底失控了，因为安迪毁了我的活动。哦。是的，我去找参议员说，他在毁掉一切，我只是很难过。但大部分时间里，我这整周都在笑，
which was lovely, and we did have a very extensive hair meeting. I remember the vision they wanted is that Angela Martin wants to be like Jackie Kennedy, right? She wants that sort of bufant hair that flipped out at the end, you know? So yeah, that was our whole look. I love that. You guys had a story behind the heritage.
这很可爱，我们确实开了一个非常详尽的发型会议。我记得他们想要的视觉效果是，安吉拉·马丁想成为杰奎琳·肯尼迪那样的人，对吧？她想要那种在发尾翻卷的蓬松发型，你知道吗？所以，是的，这就是我们的整体造型。我喜欢这样。你们发型背后的故事。
Yes, and this is the second time that Angela Martin has tried to look like Jackie Kennedy. You remember she wore the pillbox hat? Yes. And the blue suit to Phyllis's wedding. Something that's interesting to me is would Angela support the Kennedy politics? Or it's just the fashion. I'm not sure about. Is it an interesting choice of role model? I'm surprised that she doesn't fashion herself after Nancy Reagan.
是的，这是安吉拉·马丁第二次试图看起来像杰奎琳·肯尼迪。你记得她戴了药盒帽吗？是的。还有那套蓝色西装去参加菲yllis的婚礼。对我来说有趣的一点是，安吉拉会支持肯尼迪的政治吗？还是仅仅因为时尚。我不太确定。这是一个有趣的榜样选择吗？我很惊讶她没有把自己打扮成南希·里根的风格。
Well, you know, she was Nancy Reagan for Halloween. This is true. I think she just wants to be a politician's wife. Yes, she doesn't care. She doesn't care. The political't care the political affiliation. That's right. If you have a good suit or a nice hat, she's going to try it out. I've got a location breakdown for this banquet hall.
好吧，你知道，万圣节时她就是南希·里根。这倒是真的。我想她只是想成为一个政治家的妻子。是的，她不在乎。她不在乎。政治立场是什么。没错。如果你有一套好西装或一顶漂亮的帽子，她就会去尝试。我为这个宴会厅做了一个地点细分。
We got a fan question from Haley in Austin, Texas asking, where were the fundraiser scenes shot? At five minutes and three seconds, there's a shot of the outside of the building. Is that also the actual building that the scenes were shot in? These are very savvy questions. This is a long time listener. Haley knows that it could be different places. That's right.
我们收到了来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的黑利的一个粉丝提问，问筹款活动的场景是在哪里拍摄的？在5分3秒时，有一个建筑外观的镜头。这也是拍摄场景的实际建筑吗？这些是非常精明的问题。这是一个老听众。黑利知道可能会是不同的地方。没错。
I asked Steve Burgess about this. He said we shot the ballroom fundraiser scenes at the Warner Center Marriott in Woodland Hills. We were there for two days. Steve said that he remembers sending a camera crew outside one night to get an establishing shot, but he couldn't find it anywhere on his schedule. So it is very possible that we used like a stock-footed shot of a hotel. So he's not totally sure, but we did go on
我问过史蒂夫·伯格斯这件事。他说我们在伍德兰山华纳中心万豪酒店拍摄了宴会厅筹款活动的场景。我们在那里待了两天。史蒂夫说他记得有一天晚上派摄制组出去拍一个建立镜头，但在他的日程表上到处都找不到。所以很有可能我们用的是酒店的资料库存镜头。所以他不太确定，但我们确实去了
location to shoot the fundraiser banquet scenes. But either way, Steve Burgess said that the banner on the outside of the building, that was added in post. We did not actually hang a banner on a building. Andy is now gonna have a talking head. He says, you know what? Where do I look? You know, it's been so long since I've done
one of these interviews. Yeah. Yeah. How am I doing? I'm doing great. Red flag. I mean, there's these interviews. Yeah. Yeah. How am I doing? I'm doing great. Red flag. I mean, there's so many red flags. Yeah.
Well, just wait. There's going to be a flag flurry coming up. A flag flurry. Kevin and Cree are going to check out the auction table. And that's when Dwight is going to come up and tell them that they're doing it all wrong, that they're idiots. They haven't guessed the correct price of anything. Mm-hmm.
And Kevin tries to correct Dwight, but Dwight is just taking over. He's just writing down a bunch of amounts and Kevin's like, oh, I find. Kevin has a talking head where he says Dwight doesn't understand what a silent auction is, which means he's the stupid guy in the office. Up till now, they didn't have one. Can I tell you, that was not the scripted talking head. It wasn't. It wasn't.
That was the candy bag alt. The scripted talking head was this. Huh, I know more than Dwight. You know what they say, even a clock is right once a day. Oh. And they went with the candy bag. Which is very funny because the saying is that a clock is right twice a day, a broken clock. It's right. It's not the same. I don't know. But yeah, I
thought this was a great example of when they actually went with one of the alts and didn't use the one that was in the shooting draft. Well, I really like the detail of seeing Dwight guessing prices in the background of Kevin's talking head. And I went to the script and I noticed that that was not scripted. That was a directing choice by Dave Rogers. And I absolutely loved it. It really added to the realism of the moment for me.
You know, my husband is very, very good at guessing prices of things. Like he would kill it on the prices, right? He would kill it. I went on the prices, right? I didn't make it up on the stage, but when I first moved to LA, you're in the audience. Yeah. I waited in line for hours with two of my friends. I got the little price tag with my name on it. It said Regina, because that's my legal name. They have to put your legal name on your price tag. And so I sat in the audience and I did my best to like wave and try to get up on stage. I really wanted to be on. I wanted to win money to like pay for my apartment.
Well, yeah. Because I just moved here. But you probably just put in one like a jet ski. And then you're like, what do I do with two jet skis? Well, poor Pam knows the fate of having two jet skis in her life that she doesn't want. But you know those things I heard that if you win like an actual prize, like a washer dryer or jet ski or something, before you can get your prize, you have to pay the taxes. So if you win two jet skis that are worth like $7,000, first you have to pay the taxes. Oh, you know, you get your jet skis, so worth like $7,000. First, you have to pay the taxes before you get your jet skis. So you get like a bill. Yeah, but I think you can also, I believe. Can you just say, can I just have the cash value?
I think you can. And then they deduct the taxes out of the cash value. I wonder how many people do that. And then now my brain is going to like, is there a giant warehouse of like rejected jet skis and washer and dryers? That's a good question. What do they do with the floor models of the things?
But also, they don't send you the thing that was in the actual episode, right? Don't they just send you something like direct? How do they get it to you? Oh my God, I have so many questions. There's so many questions about how game shows work. This is why you just want to go on press your luck and win the big bucks, right? There's no item you have to deal with. I want if you have to pay for shipment. So I won two jet skis. Now I got to pay for them to be delivered to my house where I have no place to store them. What do you do if you win one of the goats?
Goats? Yeah, remember on, um, let's make a remember on... Let's make a deal. Remember let's make a deal. Sometimes behind door number two, it would just be like a goat. Oh. That doesn't seem fair to the animal. Yeah, I mean does anyone take the goat? What's the cash value of a goat? I don't think I've ever seen that show.
Let's make a deal? Yeah, I've never seen it. Yeah, you win something and then you can trade it for whatever is behind door number one, two or three, but it's like a blind pick. Can you not trade if you don't want to trade? Yeah, you don't have to trade. You can just keep the thing you want. But usually something better is behind one of the doors. Like door number one will have, you know, like a new washing machine or like new kitchen appliances. Door number two will be like an all-expense paid vacation to the Bahamas and then door number three is goat.
You know, and you can pick it. You can say, I'm going to pick door number one. And then they say, are you sure you want door number one or do you want to trade like it's a psychological torture? Yeah, it sounds horrible. Yeah. And then you've got a poor goat in a door. You don't hear it. You don't hear the goat. It's a good question. I never thought about it. If you can hear the goat.
Or smell it. Okay. Well, we clearly do not produce game shows. Because if we did, maybe for good reason. Very mismanage. We'd get very hung up on the smallest details. I hope someone's hung up on the details. Where are we? I don't know. Oh, Andy is holding court with Aaron Pam, Jim and Ryan, and he's started, oh dear, talking about his rock opera. Yes, that he's been writing.
I'm sorry that he's been receiving. Yes, he's been receiving the rock opera. He's been speaking. Mm-hmm's been receiving the rock opera. Yeah. Disgust Orion, and it really made me laugh because he immediately goes, Andy's having a breakdown. Oh yeah. Oscar now has a storyline that is so funny.
I just was so tickled by Oscar Nunez's performance of this, like his joy. He's just giddy because he's chatting with the Senator, telling him that he loves animals, his dog Gerald is his whole life. And the Senator gives him his cell phone number. Tells him, you know what, the best time to call me is after 9 p.m. You know Angela goes to bed at like 8.30. You know she does. We got a letter about that Angela from Justine R in Naples Italy who said, In season 5, episode 1, Angela tells us, quote,
I have a nice comforter, a few cozy pillows. I usually read a chapter of a book and it's lights out by 830. Yes! And that's how I sleep at night. That's right! So it's true by 9pm, she is asleep. And the Senator is free to chat with Oscar. Oscar is a talking head where he says three things are now confirmed. He's right about the senator. He's still got it. And a poor Angela.
Yeah. Now Andy is gonna pitch his rock opera to Robert California. You mean Bobby? Bobo. Oh no. The rock opera is very convoluted. There's an evil figure named Thomas Organ, who
wants to destroy all the guitars in the world. Yeah. The hero of the story, we don't find out his name, is based on Andy. And Andy's going to sing us a few lines of the heroes, I guess, Ballad. Yeah, it goes something like this. We're flying so high, we're cracking the sky,
gonna fly out of this dome, my girlfriend and I. Meredith is like, hey, Gibroni, show some class. Yeah, Stanley also agrees he's a Gibroni. What is a Gibroni? I had to know, I'd never heard this term. Did you Google? Of course I Google too. I do. I mean, well, let's never heard this term. Did you Google? Of course I Googled it. I Googled too.
I mean, well, let's both cheer about it. All right, what'd you find? I found on espn.com in 2020 that Gibroni is officially in the dictionary. They added 650 new words in 2020 and Gibroni was one, which of course led me to what is the origin and meaning of Gibroni. Yeah and meaning of Gibroni? Yeah, I guess Gibroni means a foolish or contemptible person, and it has its origins in the Italian language.
Well, I had never heard this term before, Angela, but I guess the rock made it famous in the wrestling world. That's how it ended up in the dictionary was because he brought it into the popular vernacular. I have an audio clip. If you'd like to hear the rock throwing out some gibbonies, let's hear it. And then one of you gibbonies pulls the handles and there it is. One Brahma Bull, two Brahma Bulls, three Brahma Bulls! You gibbonies hit the jackpot and then all of a sudden you're jumping around like a bunch of idiots under tanker with his Mickey Mouse tattoos and his 33 pound head.
So this word caught fire in the wrestling community and I guess it caused a little bit of a stir though Angela Angela, because apparently the Iron Sheik was the first person to use this word and he would say this a bunch backstage. But when the rock came out with it, it became super popular. So the rock did actually give credit to the Iron Sheik for being the person who put it in his ear. Yes, I read that the rock said, talking about the iron chic, his impact on my career has been really profound. And the word jabroni is connected to me,
but when a lot of people think, oh, jabroni, yeah, yeah, yeah, it's the rock's word. No, no, no, it's not my word. It's the iron chic's word. Classy. Classy. Credit where credit is to. That's right. You know what?
I mean, just from that clip, I feel like wrestling is so much yelling. It is a lot of yelling. What a yelling like you got to be your own hype man. Oh yeah, that's a big part of it. Wow. Okay. Well, Meredith knew what a Gibroni was, so did Stanley, and they tell Andy to stop being
one. And then, Andy accuses Stanley of being a Thomas Orrigan. And Robert says Andrew, I think this might have been a bad idea. Yeah. Why don't you let me pay for you and Aaron to go out to a great romantic dinner tonight. Andy's like, you don't need to pay for me. I'm doing just fine. Why don't you quit harsh and armello? Oh, Andy. Yeah. Robert asks him to leave. But instead, Andy is going to call over a waiter and he says, I'd like to purchase another
seat at this fundraiser. The waiter's like, I'm sorry, we only sell seats by the table. So Andy says, I'll purchase a table. A whole table. That's expensive. Expensive, but then as the episode continues, not only did he buy a whole table, but like, he wants to have all the salads served, like Andy come on. He's sitting there all by himself.
I've got some deets on our waiter guest star. He was played by Christian S. Anderson. He's also appeared on Key and Peel, Castle and Will and Grace. Nice. You know, when you see Andy sitting at the table and he's getting the pepper, you know, on his salad, you really get a great shot of those beautiful yellow flower arrangements in the center. The daffodils. The daffodils.
Mm-hmm. Lady in my digital clutter. I emailed you that I got to take one of the arrangements home. You did? Yes. Well, you know, there's a whole deleted storyline about Pam and Phyllis fighting over who gets to take a centerpiece home. It was a whole runner that got cut out of the episode.
That's so great. That's hilarious to me. Yeah. So I guess when we wrapped out, Phil had all these extra flowers and he gave them to anyone who wanted them and I took them home. Well, you know, I got curious about those daffodils because I thought they were so beautiful and I remembered that storyline with Phyllis. Mm-hmm.
I wanted to know how much money did they spend on those daffodils centerpieces? Because they are, by far, the most elaborate flowers I've ever seen in an episode of the show. Yeah. According to the internet, 100 daffodils cost about $150. I frees framed on one of the arrangements.
Did you count the daffodils? At least 40 in each one. Can your autobiography be called counting the daffodils? Yes. Yes it can. Yeah, that sums me up. It really does. So I'm thinking that with at least 40 daffodils
plus the basket plus the labor plus the markup on flowers. I think each one of these cost at least a hundred bucks. And there were so many we spent so much on flowers. I should have asked Steve Burgess what our flower budget was, but I'm telling you you got a nice arrangement Angela. I did. And I'm telling you you would have kicked ass on the prices right. Thank you. Thank you. I'm only they'd called on me. I know. Oscars now gonna return to his seat. He's so delighted.
He cannot wait to tell them the senator is hitting on him. Jim's like, you know what, Oscar? Okay, I think you're misinterpreting this. Oscars like, no, no, no, he gave me the look. And then he does the look. And Pam's like, whoa, oh my gosh. And Jim's like, come on. And Pam's like, twice, he did that twice.
And then Jim goes, okay guys, not every glance means something, all right. Life isn't Downton Abbey and Pam goes, life is Downton Abbey. It did make me look up some of the best quotes of the Dauroger Countess, aka Lady Violet Crawley. Okay. I found a website that said you can take Lady Violet Crawley's quotes and use them in business. Ooh, I'm intrigued. Okay, here's one. There's nothing simpler than avoiding people you don't like.
Avoiding one's friends. That's the real test. like avoiding one's friends. That's the real test. Every woman goes down the aisle with half the story hidden. Oh, it's the job of grandmothers to interfere. You are a woman with a brain and reasonable ability. Stop whining and find something to do. Business mantras from the Dowager Countess.
I don't see them necessarily as business mantras, but they do seem like a nice guide for introverts. I had a little catch in this episode, and you can really see it in this scene with Oscar and Jim and Pam, which is that I'm wearing the tennis bracelet that Jim gave Pam, which is that I'm wearing the tennis bracelet that Jim gave Pam for Christmas.
And I loved this detail. Phil Shea got it out. For this episode, he kept all of my jewelry in a little box. And whenever there was a fancy event, Pam would wear her tennis bracelet. I love it. It's Phil Shea, man, painting the picture. Mm-hmm. Well, we should take a break because when we come back, Jim is now going to go up to the
Senator to see if he gets his cell phone number two. That's right. All right, we are back. And Dwight is hard at work. He's guessing the price of all the auction items. He says this is like taking candy from a baby. I have a really fun catch in this scene. I love a fun catch.
What do you got? Did you notice the family photo on the auction table? Like I think probably it's, or like a family photo session with the talker. I saw that, that's what I thought. I thought it's like, oh, you get like a Sears photo package. Yes. I am pretty certain that the person in the photo is our on set dresser, Sean Farrell.
And I think that's his family. Oh, it's so cute. Cute. Yes. So cute. Well, now Andy is going to bump into David Wallace. And he's going to share with him that he got fired. Mm-hmm.
And David's like, that's the best thing that happened to me. Yeah. He's getting fired. Mm-hmm. He poured himself into his sucket vacuum and guess what? The military bought it for $20 million. For $20 million dollars. And then David Wallace was like, you know what Andy, you got to move on.
You got to forget about Dunderclund. And that's where the scene ended. But there was more. Oh good, because we got a forget about Dunderclund. And that's where the scene ended, but there was more. Oh good, because we got a fan mail flurry about this scene. Oh, okay. Are you ready? Jason T from Houston, Texas says, it seems odd that David Wallace appears
without others noticing him. It's not like the banquet room is packed. Did some other things happen off camera? I mean, you'd assume Jim would spend some time catching up with David Wallace. And Teresa B. from New Jersey said, Are there deleted scenes that help explain David Wallace's presence? Hoping Angela can come through. Well, Teresa, Jason, I have a little something here that might explain it.
So the scene was scripted that Andy is actually exiting the restroom when he bumps into David Wallace. And the whole top of the scene is the same, but then David at the end says, point is, forget those guys, move on. And then Andy would have said, move on. I'm parting with them tonight. David says, really? Wow, okay.
So the scene was scripted that Andy is actually exiting the restroom when he bumps into David Wallace. And the whole top of the scene is the same, but then David at the end says, point is, forget those guys, move on. And then Andy would have said, move on. I's parting with them tonight. David says, really? Wow, okay.
That sounds very awkward to me. I don't think I would have come if I knew Dundermifland was coming. Hmm, then there's a beat and he goes, hey, but you know what, make sure you tell everyone, I sold Suck It for a ton of money, okay? See ya, and then he walks away. So it sounds like to me, he doesn't want to see the Dundermifland crew. He wouldn't have even come if you knew they were gonna be there.
How does he not know they're going to be there? Isn't it like common knowledge that Angela is the senator's wife? And also, I have to agree with Jason from Houston. This is not a large room. I mean, yeah. I can see everybody clearly. Yeah. Where is David sitting?
What about all of the hobnobbing that happened maybe pre-dinner or at the auction tables? There's so much hobnobbing at these things. Yes, there is. I know. Well, I think of the Dundermiffling crew he would have said hi to Jim. Yes. And while it might have been scripted that the scene takes place outside of a restroom, that was definitely not clear to me.
It looks like he's just right in the ballroom. Yeah. Well, I found it interesting in the script that David wouldn't have come if you knew the Dundermifling crew was there. What's his beef with the Dundermifling crew? He's moved on. He's moved on.
Well, now Nelly is gonna try to bond with Darrell. She's complaining about the food, said she'd give anything for just a burger or pizza pie or whatever else they like. Darryl suggests tacos. And it is so clear that Nelly has no idea what a taco is. Yeah, she has a talking head where she says she's never had a taco. She's hoping that they're not slimy and don't have eyes. I would like to say that Nelly pining away for different food really tracks if you look
at everybody's plate. I only saw myself eating at the table and I think I had requested a plate of vegetables but you'll notice that Jim's fish goes untouched the entire episode. So yeah. I could see how maybe Nelly wanted something else. I will tell you what's pretty gross is if you do like a 12-hour scene and you have like a meatloaf or something on a plate in front of you that you have to push around for 12 hours and pretend to eat. I couldn't believe that I don't have memories of the fish that was on John's
plate for all those scenes with me and John and Oscar. Because it's just sitting there the whole time. It never changes. Speaking of our table, Jim is going to return to the table. And guess what? He got the Senator's cell phone number. Yeah, he did. How about that Oscar? Well Oscar and Pam say Jim hasn't proven anything. All he's proven is that maybe the Senator thinks Jim is gay. Then they make fun of Jim's shoes. They say no gay man would wear those shoes. Yeah, Jim's like you bought me these shoes. Why are you making fun of my shoes? My shoes that you bought me. It was very funny. Robert California is now going to take to the podium.
He's going to speak about saving elderly dogs, who he calls heroes, fan catch from Timothy B. In Germany, background catch, when the senator is introducing Robert California, you can see Angela Malfa along the words. Yes, that was a choice I made. I improvised that. I just figured she would know his whole introduction. There's actually more in deleted scenes where he gets up and speaks and every time he does, the camera would find me and I would be saying all of his lines with him. I like that choice, that tracks. Thank you. We had a fan question from Megan W. in Massachusetts
who wanted to know, Angela, were there any deleted scenes or talking head alts during which Angela comments about this fundraiser being for dogs and not cats? I was surprised Angela's talking head about the fundraiser didn't include any snide remark. All we see is the side look that she gives to the dog during Robert California speech. Megan, that's such a good question. You know, I think she was so pleased to be part of a fundraiser event with her politician husband. And even though maybe it wasn't for anything she truly cares about, she still gets to be up front and center, right? So that's why I think there's no snarky comment in the talking head. But there's only one mention of Angela Martin's attitude towards the event in the shooting draft, and it happens when the senator is introduced. In the script it said, Robert
California says, why do we love dogs? And then there's this stage direction, angle on Angela, not buying the premise. And I remember, like when I read that, I was like, how do I convey that? And then I just, there was a dog right next to me. So I thought, oh, well, look at it, I'll roll my eyes, I'll be grossed out. The true Angela does bleed to the rear. Just for a little moment.
Mm-hmm. Andy is gonna interrupt Robert California's speech, and he is going to volunteer to take all of the elderly dogs home with him, and I guess adopt them. All of them? Yes. It's so many dogs. Well, now we're gonna see Andy.
He's with the animal welfare volunteer who's walking him through the different various needs of these dogs. They all have special needs. One of the dogs, Kenny, is a therapy dog and he's really bonding with Andy. And the animal welfare volunteer says, you know what? He must think you're in the midst of an emotional crisis. Yes. Our animal welfare volunteer was played by Andrew Segunda. He was a writer on late night with Conan O'Brien and the Goldbergs. He also played Dr. Ewing in the League,
and he co-hosts a Star Trek, the next generation rewatch podcast called Star Trek, the Next Conversation. Oh, I'll also have you know, we did not shoot these scenes at the hotel. Haley, who asked us about locations, this room was a set that we built on the warehouse stages. And we also got a fan question from Katie Jo B, an Indiana and Nicole L from Canada who said, please tell us everything about the senior dogs. Are they from the normal animal training rental company?
Were all the dogs actors or were any of them actual rescues at the time? Well, guys, all the dogs came through, Bob done. Not really a surprise there. They were not rescues. They were working dogs. We had three trainers to take care of the six dogs. They worked for two days, one day on this little set that we built,
and one day at the Marriott and the total cost for the dogs and trainers was about $6,000. I also asked Steve Burgess if he had the doggy headshots for each of our dog actors. And he did. Bella was played by Scout, and the other dog actors were Lucy Monkey, Langley, Bullet, and Duke. I will put their headshots and stories. Steve said when they talked to the animal trainers about what each dog would have to do, these were the dogs that they recommended for those roles.
I see, I love that. They were cast based on their ability. Yes, they had their specialties. Oh dear, guess what's gonna happen now? The senator is gonna give Meredith his cell phone number. Well, that blows Oscars theory. That's right. Jim still has an eatenus fish, I tracked it.
Oscars now gonna have a talking head where he says, he's not disappointed that Angela's husband wasn't hitting on him. He'd have to be a monster to root for that. A lonely aging monster. Mm, poroscar. Darrell returns with tacos, and Nelly doesn't know how to eat one.
It's like she's, I don't know, scooping the ingredients into her mouth from the shell. She's not biting into the shell. We got a fan question from Gen G in Kentucky who said, I'm a theater professor and I specialize in women in comedy and improv.
And this episode has one of my favorite bits of physical clowning in the entire series. And it is when Nelly tries to eat a taco. I desperately need to know how she came to this bit, to what degree it was scripted, and to what degree it emerged from the magical mists of Catherine Tate's fabulous mind. Well, Jen, this taco eating was scripted. Here's what it said. Quote, Nelly picks up the taco, unsure how to eat it, then puts it to her mouth sideways with her finger pushes the filling down her throat. And then this little bit got cut. It said, Nelly holds the empty shell and looks around and says,
savory, is there a plate for the shells? So this was a combo platter of scripting and also though, of course, Catherine Tates' interpretation of what was scripted. Yeah. Well, her attempt at trying to eat a taco, it tugs on Daryl's heartstrings. He's starting to soften. He has a talking head and he says she's trying. Yeah.
It's time now to announce the auction winners. Guess what, guys? Dwight wins the first item and the second and the third. Well, you know what, guess what? He's won them all. Yes, the MC says I'm going to save us some time. And just announced that Dwight Shrew won everything and they are so grateful for his donation of over $34,000.
It's the largest they've ever received. Thus begins a standing ovation, started by Jim. Oh yeah. It was scripted that Jim would start the ovation and yell speech, but I personally love John's choice of also being the last person standing in clapping. Yeah. Oh, I feel like I should let you know our MC guest star was played by Elizabeth Payne, who was our writer, Hallstead Sullivan's high school prom date.
Ah. Hallstead said he had nothing to do with her casting. She's a working actor. He didn't even know that she got cast on the show and was in this episode until they screened this episode for the writers. Come on! Yeah, he said, you know, if you weren't the writer of the episode, you stayed in the writer's room most of the time. Yeah.
So, yeah. He said Elizabeth is also a successful voice actress. She voiced the pre-crime voice in the minority report. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. And if you watched the first season of Ugly Betty, she played the mysterious masked woman on the show. I guess there was a woman on the show
who had plastic surgery to change her identity and no one knew who she was. And when she was finally unmasked, she was played by Rebecca Romaine. But before that, it was Elizabeth Payne. Hmm. Well now Dwight's gonna go up and make his speech. Everyone's chanting speech, speech.
He says he's really proud to support whatever this is, and that money is no concern to him. But when did it all become about money? He's trying to get out of it. Yes. He says, what did we spend on the flower arrangements? So, white wine, sprinters, how many courses did they have tonight? Three, if they chose pudding, and they should be ashamed of themselves.
What a waste! They're here for the dog society. And that's what's important. That is his donation. Good night. And he runs out of the room. Do you think he ever paid the money? No. You don't think. I don't think. I think the whole event was like a debacle. As the evening starts to wrap up, Oscar is going to say goodnight to the senator, and the senator says, don't forget to call. And then he lets his hand linger down
as Oscar's arm. He brings his hand from the shoulder to the wrist with a series of little squeezes, suggestive squeezes. That was all scripted, but he would run his hand down Oscars arm. Well, Oscar has a talking head where he's like, I still got it basically, and oh my God, I feel a bit for Angela. Why does this always happen to me? Ha!
Andy is now learning to put a diaper on one of the new dogs, and that's when Jim and Pam and Kevin and Aaron come in to check on him, and he's like, I'm doing great! Doing great! We got a fan mail flurry about this scene, Ainsley said it was maybe our biggest fan mail flurry yet. You're kidding, the whole time? The whole time of the whole series that we've been rewatching. Please tell me what it was. You're kidding. The whole time? Of the whole series that we've been rewatching.
Please tell me what it was. At the end of the fundraiser, when we see all the dogs that Andy has adopted, you can see Andy and April's three-legged dog champion from Parks and Rec. Oh, wow! Yeah. So people notice that we used the same dog as champion in Parks and Rec. Famous dog spotting basically, fan mail flurry. Kevin is gonna try to be the voice of reason again in the scene. Yeah.
请告诉我那是什么。在募捐活动的最后，当我们看到安迪收养的所有狗狗时，你能看到安迪和阿普丽尔在《公园与休憩》里那只三条腿的狗“冠军”。哦，哇！是的。所以人们注意到我们用了和《公园与休憩》里一样的狗作为“冠军”。基本上就是发现了名狗，粉丝来信如雪花般飞来。凯文在这个场景里又要试图扮演理性的声音了。是的。
And no one's really listening. Kevin has a talking head race that sometimes he thinks the people he works with are idiots. Sometimes meaning all times. All the times, every of the time. In our tag for this episode, we're gonna learn that the dogs have been, I guess, divided up between different folks at Dunder Mithland, Darryl has Pepper, Kevin has Ruby, so Aaron and Andy didn't end up with all 12 dogs. But they probably have a couple.
而且根本没人听。凯文有一个访谈镜头，说他有时觉得跟他一起工作的人都是白痴。有时意思是所有时候。所有时候，无时无刻。在本集的尾声中，我们会了解到这些狗狗们被分给了邓德·米夫林的其他人，我猜，达里尔养了佩珀，凯文养了露比，所以亚伦和安迪并没有包揽全部12只狗。但他们可能养了几只。
They have more than one, for sure. Because no Angela didn't take one. Well Pam and Jim didn't clearly take one. We learn the most about Kevin's dog Ruby. He says she's a good girl. She doesn't eat or poop. She just lays there. It's very clear that everyone thinks maybe she's dead. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, he says she smells really bad, but he's afraid that if he puts her in a bath, she'll drown because, you know, even to watch TV, he has to properize open. And then there's a very cute scene with Kevin Ann Ruby. They're laying on the floor together. He tells her that everyone is so interested in her and they must be jealous and she just starts licking him and it's so cute.
他们肯定养了不止一只。因为安吉拉没有拿一只。好吧，潘和吉姆显然也没有拿一只。我们对凯文的狗露比了解得最多。他说她是个好女孩。她不吃东西也不拉屎。她就躺在那儿。很显然，大家都觉得她可能已经死了。嗯。对。我的意思是，他说她闻起来很臭，但他担心如果给她洗澡，她会淹死，因为，你知道的，就连看电视，他都得把她的眼睛撑开。然后凯文和露比有一个非常可爱的场景。他们一起躺在地板上。他告诉她，每个人都对她很感兴趣，他们一定很嫉妒，然后她就开始舔他，真的太可爱了。
And she's not dead. She's not dead. She just likes to nap and doesn't like to bathe. Or eat or poop. Yeah. We had a fan question from Brendan W. and Indianapolis Indiana who said regarding the ending scene about Kevin's dog Ruby. We're led to believe that his dog is dead but he just doesn't realize it.
而且她没死。她没死。她只是喜欢打瞌睡，不喜欢洗澡。也不喜欢吃东西或拉屎。是的。我们收到了来自印第安纳州印第安纳波利斯的布伦丹·W的粉丝提问，他说，关于凯文的狗露比的结尾场景。我们不禁以为他的狗已经死了，只是他自己没意识到。
Was it originally intended to end that way? Where Ruby is truly dead? Or was it always the right or intent for the dog to actually be alive? Well, Brendan, it was always the intent that she was actually alive. Yes. I did wonder myself in that final scene with Kevin if maybe the dog started looking his face like like and we kept it, but it was supposed to end with him just talking to this Comato's dog. Yeah, but no that was a whole little trick that they taught the dog to kiss his face on that certain word Isn't that amazing? Yeah, I know. So yeah scripted and achieved dog actors They're very impressive. Mm-hmm. Well, there you have it folks that's fundraiser. Thank you so much for listening and sending in your questions and comments. Thank you
原本是打算以那种方式结束吗？露比真的死了？还是说这只狗其实还活着一直都是剧本的设定或意图？嗯，布伦丹，一直以来的意图都是她其实还活着。是的。我自己在这个和凯文的最后场景中也在想，如果这只狗开始舔他的脸，就像……像这样，我们就把它保留下来，但它本应该以他只是跟这只昏迷的狗说话来结束。是的，不过不是的，那是他们教狗狗在某个词时亲吻他脸的一个小把戏，不是很神奇吗？是的，我知道。所以，是的，有剧本且训练有素的狗狗演员们。它们非常令人印象深刻。嗯。好吧，各位，这就是《募捐活动》。非常感谢你们的收听并发送你们的问题和评论。谢谢。
to Steve Burgess and Hallstead Sullivan for sharing with us such fun behind the scenes details. And thank you for all your questions, some great fan catches in this episode. Really good ones. We'll see you next week. Bye! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy,
史蒂夫·伯吉斯和霍尔斯特德·沙利文与我们分享了如此有趣的幕后细节。谢谢你们所有的提问，这集中有一些很棒的粉丝发现。真的很棒的发现。我们下周见。再见！感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的驻场工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，
and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及我们的助理制作人Ainsley Bubbaco。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。